hello everybody
welcome to the new year in a new meetup
thank you everyone for coming it's good
to see everybody here hope everyone's
having a great start to the new year i
mean you've got to be out you're in an
arm meetup to start off the new year so
i mean can't get much better than this
hope everyone is having a uh you know i
guess a wonderful time wonderful day too
or evening depending where you are i
know most of us who are from new york
are in the evening
if you're from around the world have a
good day or afternoon whatever it may be
so uh think of everyone coming for
starting off the year i am really
excited about this
as usual we will start with jobs
now of course the failing there is that
unlike when we're in person you can't
all announce what jobs you have
available
but if you go to the slack the meetup
slack the nyhakar.slack.com
and you go there there is a channel just
for jobs
recently blue rose research and our
studio posted
online med ed posted and going on and on
there's lots of jobs posted so if you're
looking for a job involving data science
go to the job postings of nyhack r
since i am on screen i am looking to
hire for my company all sorts of roles
looking for a sales person who is
technical and understands the
inner workings of data science or at
least the outer workings of data science
we're looking for shiny developers we're
looking for systems engineers someone
who's good at linux we're looking for a
project manager and we're looking for a
data scientist
all these jobs could be full-time or
part-time in new york or remote whatever
you folks are looking for so if you are
interested in one of those many roles i
listed for lander analytics uh message
me
you can find me in the slack you can
find me on twitter you can find me by
email many many many ways to get in
touch with me so again lots of positions
most of them are posted at
landeranalytics.com careers but not all
of them we need to post the rest of the
jobs but again looking for sales shiny
data scientists systems engineers
project manager whole bunch of rules
as usual pizza
my pizza came from village pizza it's it
had terrible cheese lock when i got it
but it's been sitting around for a
little bit
you see not too much charge on the
bottom it is a gas deck oven so it
didn't char too much
uh so folks sound off and let me know
where you got your pizza from i'm always
interested in seeing where you got your
pizza or other lesser food i'm very
happy to always see what you folks have
i'm always looking forward to this and
one day hopefully soon we will all be
eating pizza together
um we don't quite know when yet and i'll
cover that a little bit um but hopefully
someone could eat pizza i see that john
makes his own pizza which is very cool
you need to send a photo in the in the
slack send us a photo of your pizza in
fact everyone that's one of the things
if you have questions for the speaker
you obviously can't ask questions
because none of you can speak
unfortunately well none of you can speak
in this meetup a meeting unfortunately
so if you go to our slack
and we will post a link how to sign up
for it if you don't have it
and go to the monthly meetup chat
channel you can ask questions there and
i will collate them and ask zj these
questions at the end of the talk
so please if you have questions go there
or if you want to post pictures of your
pizza or whatever food you're eating put
that in the monthly meetup chat as well
let's uh make this as social as it is
normally when we are in person
i'd like to thank ecohealth alliance for
providing us with this zoom link they've
been doing this for nearly two years now
um so thank you very much ecohealth for
helping us reach everyone around the
world
um a few upcoming events
next month we will have hans speaking
about duck db
uh those who don't know duck db is this
new i want to say that's it's new but
i'm not sure how new it is anymore it's
a database it's sort of like sql light
but it's really meant for scientific
computing and it can use um part k as a
backend or as an error i get a little
confused that's why hans is going to be
speaking we are very excited to have
hans speak and this is actually going to
be a bit of a theme we have we've had um
we have disc.frame today we have duckdb
next month we had arrow not too long ago
i think we had one other one also we
have a theme of these extra memory
data manipulation libraries so february
i think we have a date february 24th i
think but we'll announce that it'll be
an official date
then in march we have bill uh he's
spoken at a few of our meetups before
and he will actually be talking about
the brooklyn bridge
and how it relates to data science so
that's going to be a very cool talk so
come check out
bill in march
then in june
8th through 10th we have the new york r
conference
i know it feels like we might have just
had it back in september we had the gov
conference in december we are actually
planning far in advance now for june 8th
through 10th the new york r conference
we are planning on it being
in person and virtual it will be both
and i'm very excited to have it both in
person and virtual now we said that last
year it was going to be in person
virtual and i think at that point it was
a delta variation that hurt us then we
said that our government conference
would be in person but then the omicron
variant hurt us
so we are planning to be in person june
8th through 10th
if it's not safe we have learned to
pivot like that on two weeks notice
hopefully it'll be both virtual and in
person
the official announcement is coming out
next week tickets will go on sale of
early bird specials
you can get tickets at rstats.ai
and you can use code nyhakar for 20
discount as members of the meetup so we
are really looking forward to
um
having this in person hopefully
speaking of in person we are hoping that
the meetups can return in person
fairly soon uh we were hoping well we
were hoping for last year then we're
hoping for january then we were hoping
for march now we're hoping for april or
may again we'll return to in-person and
virtual we'll do both it'll be both in
person and virtual as soon as we can
to that end we need space to host us
i know a lot of companies aren't ready
to host in person and we're not ready to
be in person but as soon as we are ready
we would like spaces so if you can host
us for the meetup we're talking about
150 people
let me know message me at
gerrylander.com on slack atlanta
analytics.com on meetup find me on
linkedin find me on anywhere let me know
about having space
we've had lots of gracious hosts in the
past and we will hope we hope to return
to them but it's always good in a city
like new york to have as many hosts as
you can so please let me know if you can
host us
please welcome from
almost as far away around the world from
new york as you can get i think there's
a few other places a little bit farther
but please everyone welcome zj to talk
to us about disc frame i'm going to give
i'm going to give an applause if you
can't hear anybody else yes
all right great
thank you very much jerry
thank you
um today i'm going to talk about the
uh disk frame package so i've showed you
the title your laptop is more capable
than you think
and
this frame is really just a
r package for manipulating
larger than ram data so um i think a
typical laptop nowadays has about 16 gig
of ram and 32 gig of ram and and
multiple cores
and i i always get the feeling that a
lot of the programs were written in the
in the in the days before
multiple cores were available or before
large amounts of ram was available i
remember you know
not that long ago maybe uh it was a lot
of laptops were still 32-bit so they did
they couldn't have put in four gig of
ram so
it was very limited but today most
laptops are 64-bit and they can have a
lot a lot more ram so 16 gig ram 32
kilogram like becoming just the norm so
and
with
that much ram coming on board and and
having more cpu cores on your laptop
are we able to
manipulate larger data sets uh
then we're
accustomed to in the past with r because
as we know r tends to just load the data
into memory and if it doesn't fit it
will throw some error like cannot
allocate a vector of this size etcetera
etcetera etcetera so
this frame is designed to solve those
type of problems
um and as we all know like if you're
working on our legs probably 80 of your
time but we spend on data cleaning and
wrangling
and i wanted to start by giving this
slide on the definitions i want to talk
about today
um so
i think of data as in kind of four
categories so you've got your trivial
data so these are data that's kind of so
small they can fit into excel so
typically less than a million rows
you've got your small data which are
basically data that can fit into your
ram so basically anything that you do in
r like data frames
data tables or in python you do pandas
so
these typically would load the data into
memory
they'll classify anything that fits into
memory nowadays it's small data
and then of course you've got your big
data where this data are just so huge
that you really need a distributed
cluster to handle effectively
and i think tools like spark or in
python
things like tasks will fit into this
category
but really that's a really huge section
of data that really isn't that
big it doesn't require a huge big data
framework to handle
they kind of sit can sit in your hard
drive which is no could be anything like
one terabyte two terabyte but you just
don't have enough ram to handle them and
this category of data really is what i
call the medium data
and they are
a very big chunk of the data science uh
well like the banks i work for
you know for example the credit card
data set would be maybe 20 gig
50 gig 100 gig it kind of fits squarely
right in there and and we used to just
use laptops to you know run through uh
50 gigs of data using some programs so
it's definitely not big data
you can definitely do it on one computer
but they're not small as well because
they can't really fit into memory so the
medium data is the the section that we
really want to focus on and this is
where this frame plays in
and in this presentation i'll really
want to
touch on a little bit about arrow and db
which has already been mentioned by
jared so they're really really
interesting and exciting tools that are
coming into the
that you can work with in the r space
um
so
i guess the the ideal medium data tool
is you know to me is free fast and easy
to set up um
and i hope
a lot more um
yeah i hope a lot more of these can can
work i just got a quick question about
um
the the curly braces for arrow it
doesn't really
mean anything i just i i sometimes just
put
square arrows around
our package names so but sometimes it's
not consistent
that's just to indicate it's our package
okay um so i have not done
a lot of benchmarking so i've
benchmarked this frame versus dusk on
one benchmark and you know and based on
that
i think that this frame is slightly
faster than dusk in some tasks but i do
not have a lot of data on that now arrow
and duckdb are kind of newer players in
this space
and i think
even though i put them on this on this
chart i actually haven't tested them
that extensively so they're really just
a placeholder but i i really you know
hold them in high regard i i think i
look at them they're really promising so
but really that's kind of what you're
looking at in terms of the the market
some medium data tools you can use spark
for this kind of data set you can run
spark on one mode
but it
in my experience becomes a bit clunky
and
you kind of it's a little bit of an
overkill and of course if you
use if your enterprise has sas
um that tends to be the slowest and
obviously the most expensive option
because it's paid for
so
enough enough background so i want to
just talk about a little bit about um
this cream now and probably give you a
demo but
um before i give a demo i think
this frame is actually really simple
that this screen format is nothing but a
folder and inside this folder you will
have
files you know labeled from one to n
in each of these files as you can see
it's a dot fst file so dot fs dot fst is
a
data frame storage format just currently
only
that's only in r and it was it was there
long before um
you know par k was a viable option in r
so that's why this film was developed
with fst it's a really fast format for
storing
data frames data it loads fast and it
compresses it and it's got some really
nice features so
really that's that's really what it is
just this frame it's a folder of dot fst
files
each file is of course a data frame
it stores a data frame and it's got
maybe a metadata folder that contains
some information about the
disk frame but not but that's basically
just it
and the key ideas behind this frame is
that as you saw
uh we have a lot of small files in a
uh a folder so basically really what it
does is it takes a big file and cuts
them up into smaller pieces
and this this there's some good reasons
for doing that one is that if you cut
them into smaller pieces then you can
have each cpu working on each distinct
chunk
um so you can enable parallelism so you
can think of a lot of the operations in
in your data frame like filter
like you don't have to filter
sequentially you know one billion rows
of data you can just filter
uh
you know each of the chunks separately
and you still get the same end result um
so you can actually do for example
things like filter uh in parallel
unless of course you depend on things
like the previous row and things like
that but um those those concepts don't
exist in uh
in a
you know large data
frame um
frameworks like this and and of course
uh
as i mentioned if you cut them up you
can do them you use all your of course
at the same time
and one of the most expensive things you
can do on a computer is actually to work
with the disk whether you have a hard
drive a spinning disk or ssd
loading data from disk into memory is
actually very expensive so it actually
makes sense to compress your data before
you
shuffle them around you know from this
to memory and fst is great for doing
that and and formats like park k are
great for doing that
and of course once you've
got your data into smaller
pieces and chunks you can apply online
algorithms or big data algorithms to
operate on at the chunks one at a time
we'll see
hopefully see a couple of these examples
okay
and really
just want to say that this one really
couldn't have been built without you
know the giants in the r fields like
data tables future
which is great for distributing you know
your processors of course fst is a great
format for storing um
data frames and of course the tidy verse
which i can't just use um
okay so
um enough about uh disk frame i just
want to go to a demo but really the main
reason i built this screen was when i
was consulting at a big bank in
australia one of the biggest banks here
they were using sas and with
like a really simple group buy
uh from a table like literally that's
the equivalent of the sql statement that
i was doing just summing up from some
column from this one big table which is
about 50 gig in size
was taking 25 minutes just a simple
query like this and if you want to do
a typical analytical workload you want
to do lots of queries like this um you
know and interactively it's it's just
not viable so that's how i ended up
developing disk frame and the same query
was you know dropped to three seconds um
so
before i go any further i just show you
a quick demo of um disk screen
connection so
this is my r studio i hope the font is
large enough for everyone to see
um
so
so really what what i have done here is
i have a directory
of files
and uh i'm just computing the the total
size of these files
it's about uh oops
i probably should have done the
[Music]
just done the format first
so it's about
190 gig of csv files so this this where
does this file come from this is the
fannie mae data set
um you can find the fannie mae data set
just by
googling
i think fannie mae
rapids ai so they they provide a
download of this mortgage data they can
just go to this data and download the
biggest data set that you see
compressed in compressed form is about
23 gig
but uncompressed is about 195 gigabytes
of csv and it's got about 1.8
billion rows
in the data set so that's that's the
data set i'm working with
so the first step you do is
uh currently this frame has to work with
dot fst file so if you start with some
csv files um you have to convert them to
uh
to this disk frame format
and the way you do that is just to use
the csv to disk frame function from the
disk frame package literally all you do
is you just pass in the the names
of the csv files so these are all the
csv files in the in the dataset
and it's a 190 gig of worth
and
that's it you tell it where to store the
data
uh you can
short the data set by learn id i'll
explain the short concept later on
and these options if you use um data
tables
you recognize them from data tables uh
it's just
because this data set actually comes
with no header
and no
and so it's better if you kind of
provide
this frame with you know what are the
classes of the columns and what are the
column names you want to call them and
all of these are set up here where i
said well the columns are this one and
the classes are character character
character numeric numeric and these
these should be the column names
um so that's it that's just to help um
uh disk frame to kind of get the correct
types and get the correct names
and
yeah
and
i just ran that to convert all the csv
to this frame
and it took about in total 20 minutes to
convert 190 gig
worth of data
and it compressed everything down to
about 20 gig
in disk frame format so
you know it tells you where this frame
is stored and this is just a printout
from uh running this function so let me
just run that
so i run that last night so this is what
you end up with um
you end up with lots of dot fst files
145 worth of them
and they would be around oh okay after
compression
there's still about 80 gig so it's still
a very
big data set that we're talking with
here
um so from 200 gig of csv it's down to
about 80 gig
in term in in fst format still a sizable
set of data
and the way you work with
data like that is basically just go
this is where i store the disk screen so
so
just to show you that this frame only
contains the ssd files and the way you
use it is really just to say well this
path
is a disk frame so just pass this part
to the disk frame function
and now fm standing for fannie mae is
just the disk frame and if you print fm
it will show you some basic information
it's like okay this is where the way it
sits
that's 144 chunks
and each chunk of course is just one
file
representing one data frame so imagine
this
this humongous data set of 1.8 billion
rows actually almost 1.9 billion rows
is
split up into 144 individual individual
files and stored in this location
so
and this frame has implemented a few uh
convenience functions um just like in
bazaar so n row and n column both work
so you can kind of inspect what's in
there so it tells you there's a 1.8
billion rows and 31 columns in a data
set you can do things like head
to inspect what the data looks like
just like normal as if it's a normal
data frame but i guess one thing to
emphasize is that at all times the data
just sits on disk it doesn't
get loaded into memory at all and when
you do a hit it literally goes to the
first file
and the fst format is great because you
can just say
load the first 100 rows and it will only
load that into memory instead of loading
or a million rows and then filtering for
100 so it makes a huge difference in
terms of performance so that's why doing
ahead on this 1.8 billion rows data it's
quite speedy just like normal i almost
don't notice it
of course things like tails are
implemented
so
let's do a first really quick demo so um
what i wanted to do is just do the
equivalent of this in sql basically
on a group by this column at this column
on a sum um
some the um
i want to sum the
uh this column
and
i would just um
show the rest
uh
okay so
okay just let me okay i'll just i'll
just go ahead and do that um actually
what i noticed was that um
for some reason this is actually an
older this is actually a newer file so
age so i'm going to just do a
quick summary so basically
i'm going to change that
point h
mean
h
so if i look at the the
disk frame right so if i look at the
names yeah
of course names is another function
that's implemented so you can see that
and these are the names in the dataset i
really want to just take this lone age
which is indicates
like how long this loan has been around
i guess um oh by the way if anybody is a
mortgage day is it so it's all it's all
about the home loans and and so you see
things like loan age so
i i just want to take an average of that
and and count how many there are
uh forget about this for now um and
that's it that's that's the sql
statement i wanted to do
and the way to do that in this frame is
you just used it from a group by
statement
do you summarize um
just like you would do with um
deployer
and
now you may notice this this function
here this function here it's i read this
as source keep
but really what this does is it it tells
this frame to say
this subsequent piece of analysis only
requires
these two columns it doesn't require
anything else so when you do the
processing only load these two columns
into memory
and to me this is one of the things that
i really want to improve with this frame
because theoretically
if you just ignore this line this frame
could have just analyzed this piece of
code and figured out that hey the only
two column being used are this and this
so you didn't have to do this manually
but that hasn't been implemented yet so
for now i would say the number one speed
gain
in terms of uh working with this frame
at this stage is to really really just
kind of look at your code and figure out
which columns you're using and just say
okay only load these two columns into
memory um using this source keep um
function and this is how source keep is
different from select because select
again
uh it doesn't it's not specialized in
that it it doesn't uh tell this frame
only load those things it actually loads
everything and then select the columns
that you provided so
let me just quickly give that a run
so you can see that it's you can see it
kind of finished really quickly and
that's not because this frame has
finished really quickly it's basically
because
it's lazy
it has actually hasn't done any of this
summary yet
it's basically just
tell this claim to say well
do this
and like other systems like spark to
actually compute it you have to call
collect
so collect would you say well actually
carry this out and bring the data into
into uh memory now so let's just run
that
loan age is not uh let me i probably
just got the name wrong yep
learn island.edge
of course
and do that
run again
yep
collect
okay so let me while that's running i'll
just show you what actually happens
in terms of the um
cpu usage so you can see all the cpus
all the threads my computers are being
used up
and that's why
you know
how this frame tries to be a bit more
efficient because it's operating on all
144 chunks simultaneously
it's processing collectively
about 1.8 billion records
but it's doing it in in a way that kind
of tries to be efficient because it
tries to only load the column that you
need
and it's doing them in parallel
and
if you have no better performance ssd
coming to the market in the future like
things like the fusion drive the 3d
cross point you get even better
performance
and it's doing a really simple trick
it's just loading data
chunk by chunk in the memory
and because it's doing a chunk by chunk
it's not loading or 144 chunks of memory
it's it's not going to overwhelm the ram
so it's only going to use up you know a
little bit of the ram
as much as you need and then just dives
down so
that's how
this frame gets around this limitation
of
working with larger than ram data
because it doesn't load everything into
memory at the one time so as you can see
uh it can process about 1.8
billion rows
do a group buy on that just doing this
simple summary in about 49 seconds
um so
and the result is just you know just
like a normal
deploy operation so
um so that's that's a demo of the data
frame on a give
and and i want to just go back and talk
more about the
other features of this this frame before
giving you another demo but this time on
a much smaller data set so we don't have
to spend so much time waiting for the
operations to
to to go ahead
um
so let me just go through that the rest
of the presentation so
now
i've talked about this frame and how you
can use it to to you know uh work with
1.8 billion rows on your laptop or
desktop
um i think
i i do want to talk about when to use
this film and when not to use it
now this screen
i try to implement as many deployer verb
as possible for this frame so you can
just you know once you convert it this
frame is fairly natural so you can kind
of do most of your deployer verbs uh it
stays in r and i'll show an example
later on where
this frame can run native r code
in parallel very easily from all chunks
and this is tends to be tends to be a
feature that's not in
other distributed frameworks so
the other frameworks for example i
believe
um arrow they they would actually go
ahead and implement all the underlying
arc
functions uh independently but they
actually do not call the r functions
themselves so what that means is that
for example if you have a function
that's only available in r for example
like some sort of broom tidy
then that would not be able to be run um
inside the the arrow framework um
you you are often only allows you to run
the function they have implemented
inside the arrow framework unless you
bring everything to memory of course
um well that could be something that's
um you may want to just use this frame
for if you have really highly customized
r function that you you want to run
and of course utilize all gpus no
complexity of setup really getting this
frame is really just in store packages
this frame
so you don't have to manage the cluster
i guess if your data is not more than
hundreds of gigabytes then you probably
don't want to
get the complexity of a custom
management unless you're lucky enough to
be in a team where that's already
managed for you you know this is too big
don't use this frame and this frame is
only meant to be run on a like a laptop
or desktop
if you have things like bigquery and
you're happy with it
probably no need to use this frame
because
these things are pretty capable by
themselves if you have the budget and
the people that have already helped you
set it up
same with spark so
but i from my experience i just work
with some clients in the past they
they want to use spark but it is it's
quite small and it's they probably would
have been fine if they used the proper
tools on a on a much smaller system
instead of trying to have a cluster of
three and
where they need it
um
and i was recently i've been really
excited about things like arrow and
duckdb
uh they're very promising options i
i i'll try to spend more time to kind of
look at them
more closely
now as i mentioned before currently
this frame doesn't work with csv or
parquet directly you have to convert
them to
a fst format
but some of these tools they can they
can just operate you have maybe
100 csvs
yeah potentially you can just call into
them and operate on them directly but of
course i'm really excited about next
month the db speaker they'll
talk about that um so i want to learn
more about that as well so but i i
really haven't dug into these two tools
very deeply so i think this is my high
level understanding they may or may not
be 100 accurate
um
one thing that i find really cool with
things like arrow is that they can
support partitioning
so basically what they do is they
instead of
just storing them as
individual chunks of files you can
actually store them into folders and the
folders can have names attached to them
for example on your phone your folder
could be named
with the
month or day of the of the
um
in the folder name and you basically
store all the data relevant for that
date in that folder
so when you do a filtering or things
like date equals to that it will
directly go to that folder and skip all
the other folders so that's another way
to make things really fast and this like
this hasn't been implemented in this
frame yet but this is a very promising
thing to to implement in the future
so
um
so
i've
talked about uh some group by which i
think to me is the most important of the
data manipulation operations and you can
of course do things like merging uh left
join right join inner join
you can do them in this frame but it's a
bit clunky at the moment so i say this
frame is not very strong in this area um
i wasn't going to implement sorting of
dataframe because i thought you know in
a in a distributed framework or not it's
not distributed framework but you know
in a large data framework
you really don't want to think about
order of the columns you can't just
don't i shouldn't assume any order most
cases but
uh very lucky to have a contributor
implement this function anyway you know
for those that need it if you want to
really want to sort a big
data set
so now uh
i want to just talk about a little bit
about the
you know how to work with data frame
just to summarize you've seen the
assumption before
first thing you should do if you have a
csv just to say csv to this frame
give it some the input files where you
want to store the disk frame
and then there's some other options that
you can read about in the documentation
which i've documented
but really that's the first thing you
should do just convert any data that you
have into a disk frame
and for a lot of data sets
you can just go
okay
this frame is composed of chunks so in
the last example i showed it it's got
144 chunks
and a lot of data operations is is like
you you have a big data set but every
month you want to add some new data to
it and you will just call the add chunk
function so
add a chunk to a data frame
you can just do that and it's a great
way to convert
sql databases to this frame you just
basically set up a disk frame
uh
get some data from the sql database
but set a limit set an offset
convert that to a fst file
and then call add chunk and then go to
the next one you can keep going so in
this way
by using add chunk
together with a disk frame you can
create you can basically copy from an
sql database to this frame
which is a side note
okay i finally explained this concept of
the short key that you may have seen so
what the sharp key does is
it takes
whatever you choose to be the sharp
sharp key in in this case i've chosen
learn id so shot by loan id when i do
the conversion
so what it does is it it computes the
hash on the on the loan id
and it makes sure that
uh
the
loan id with the same hash ends up in
the same chunk
so what that means is if your learning
id is abc
and your hash happens to be one then
you're always in chunk one you've never
been anywhere else
and a lot of the analytic operations is
concerned with you know let's compute
the
average balance of this customer or the
average loan size of this customer so
it's always
you always almost always
a lot of time you're always doing things
like group by a particular customer so
if you're shop by the customer id then
those operations will be a lot faster if
you cannot already start
by storing them the same chunk in the
first place so you don't have to do any
cross-chunk communication so to
summarize for the customer the process
only has to go to one chunk summarize it
and that's it and you got your your
summarization so
choosing the shard correctly is very
important for performance and this is
true for other systems around as well
like i believe in
a system like bigquery this shard
concept is called a clustering concept
it's the same concept
um
so that's what the shark key is and it's
basically uh you have to be smart about
how you choose a shark key you don't
want to choose something that's very
skewed like if you have a categorical
column one of them is seventy percent of
the data the other ones are smaller then
you that's probably not a good choice
for a sharp key you probably want them
to be
highly random and uniformly distributed
once you
uh run a hash function on them okay but
let's just um
okay so let's do another demo now after
talking through about some of the
theories
so this is a demo uh this is going to be
a much smaller data set so i can run
through them very quickly
but again uh every time you start using
disk frame this is what i recommend you
do library
uh when you do library it will print
it'll print some instructions uh the
first time you run it about what you
should be doing and like how many
number of workers available
and
the number one thing i recommend once
you do a library this frame is to call
this function set up this frame and what
this does is
you'll basically start up a few r
sessions in the background so you can
use them to for parallel processing um
so that's
one thing so i have this data set here
uh it's a criterial data it's a
marketing data set and i'll show you
what it looks like it's it's a much
smaller data it's only three gigabyte in
size and i'm going to do the same thing
i'm going to load it load this csv into
um
into
a converter to a disk frame
optionally you can specify an output
directory if you want to keep this disk
frame permanently but if you don't set
this column what will happen is that um
i'll just store the disclaimer random
location so
i'll just run that
it's
converting a three gigabyte data set to
csv you know it's
reasonably quick
and once it's created
you can actually look at the content
um
tell you it'll tell you that hey this
data is stored in this temporary
location that's because i haven't
specified a proper output directory and
that's how many rows and how many
columns in the data set so basic
information again you can run things
like head to see exactly what the
dataset looks like just like normal
um and again
i wanna just
to summarize uh
so this is a much smaller data set so if
i don't do source keep
i can still summarize it in a reasonable
amount of time so i'll just run that i'm
just doing a group by by all of these
columns
and just doing a
an n um
and i think in
in the pi r you have to there's
convenience functions like count
but i'll just show you exactly like um
what this does but the count should also
work okay so you can summarize in around
10 seconds or eight seconds
but if you do source keep meaning i
recognize that
this
operation only requires these four
columns so only load these four columns
but otherwise it's exactly the same
operation as before
if you run that
and now the time is down to like one
second two seconds so
huge
performance boost if you tell this frame
if you spend the time to tell your
screen exactly
what columns to load so you can kind of
skip a lot of the
expensive loading data into memory
operations this way so it's a lot faster
now i want to
show some
deploy operations so first thing i do is
i'm going to do a filtering
and
let me just show you this
now again a lot of these operations are
done lazily
so you run it it's kind of immediately
returned but it actually hasn't done
anything yet
and you need to call collect to do it
but really what i want to do is figure
out how many
rows there are in this
under this filtering because this is the
treatment group and exposure so
treatment is
uh
the criteria at this data is basically
they're running a marketing experiment
and some people they show their attitude
some they don't so the one they show the
add to uh it has a treatment equals to
one otherwise zero
but if you show an online ad to someone
doesn't mean that they're they are
always um
properly exposed to the ad or maybe just
they didn't even look at it so um so
they also include a column called
exposure so exposure equals one means
they have interacted for example
interacted with the ad in some way or
whatever it may be but this is means
effective exposure to it so i only only
want to look at those that have been
effectively exposed to the ad and just
work out you know how many there are
to summarize collect and pull okay this
many
i want to do the same thing to the
control group these are people that i
haven't shown the ad to
just figure out how many there are
and i work out a ratio okay
okay and uh let me let me see this this
is working it was
there was i ran to some um art bugs in
the past
but it
it's a bit temperamental so anyway so
you can just do normal operations in
this frame we've implemented this sample
fraction so if i want to sample
from the control group
exactly this many records instead of so
i want to do some down sampling from
this number to this number this is what
i would do i just call the sample frac
function
um just to the ratio of the two and i
can just compute the
um the computer fraction of it
now this is where uh so say i have the
effective exposure data set which i've
created here
by using this filter
and i have the control group which is
i've done under different filtering rule
so i want to combine these two data set
do a row combined so this is what i do
just do alpine list this frame
um the two disclaimer i want to combine
and once i combine them into one i want
to create things like
um a target
uh which is the this formula and select
so you can see i'm just doing normal
uh
multiplier operations so once you are
bind to this frame together it will
basically take the two this frame put
them into one and store them on disk
somewhere so maybe i just separated
separate this step out first
ordering data temp
and
just do it separately and show you what
happens so um
i run that
when i run that it gives me a comment
saying okay it's appending the two
and
so this
frame data temp which comes from here is
also a disk frame so i'll show you what
happens
um again you know it's done under this
screen in some random location and the
number of rows you can see here is you
can guess is just the sum of this and
this because i literally just combined
two data frames together actually it's a
bit bigger for some reason
uh
oh anyway
uh
okay i'll check that later
so
uh it
it works it just combines the two
together and then because this is also a
disk frame
you can just
run the to mutate and select as you
normally would
so you can just see that
see what happens here
that creates
this frame
and this is something i want to show
which is that
if you want to apply arbitrary functions
on on the data frame this is what you
call it called cmap it's the c in cmap
stands for chunk
so
this is following the the per syntax for
those who are familiar with it
um
syntax
and
what it does is basically it says oh
give me this disk frame for each chunk
in the disk frame apply this function so
for those of you who are familiar with
it this is the the per syntax for
defining a function
and dot x is basically the first
argument to this function so you don't
you don't have to type the function
keyword if you use the per syntax
and what it's doing is it's calling grm
it's fitting a
model and a target using all the columns
and of course the data is each chunk
and i'm going to finish off by returning
a broom tidy of the grm models so
a broom tidy is very handy it takes the
model which
and then it converts the
return of the model into proper data
frame
so when you fit a glm normally it's like
infinite normally for the gim
like
i know it's like
maybe just do an lm just to show you the
case yeah so you get something like this
and so broom tidy is very handy
in that
it will take that and kind of converts
it into it returns a table a table
of the information that you see so
so yeah because it returns a table then
you can
to
manipulate the table so that's what room
tidy is it's purely an r function it's
not available in other
objects
or other languages
so for example if you do
use arrow or duckdb
you'll likely not be able to call this
unless you bring the data into memory
but with this frame you can just put in
our code and that's kind of
one
factor where this frame is a bit
distinct in that
you can call r code directly on the on
the chunks so so what this code does is
for each chunk fit this model but return
the outputs in a table format that's
what it does
so i just run that and hopefully no
weird errors i've been running to
weird r errors that kind of tends to be
resolved if you restart r so maybe some
issues with the um
the newer versions of r or
some package spoken or something i'm 100
sure but it it typically works um i just
go through the data
fill the model and it will collect the
models
and if you recall because each
room tidy returns a data frame
when you collect it
by default
the default collection
for cmap when you return data frames is
that you'll combine them together so
this is
um
so yeah so that's why you see a big that
what what gets returned is a big data
frame just it's just the row
the row bind of all the outputs and
that's the default behavior of cmap
in this frame you also have functions
like
emap
inside collect
list if you don't want
some of the default behavior you can
just call collect list in the collect
then it will return the results in a
list
so you have things like cmap
efr sometimes you want to be really
explicit um you just call it cmap dfr so
data frame rollbind
of course for those who are familiar
with per this is just the same as the
per
map dfr except
in
this frame i decided to put a c in front
of it to to make it clear that we're
operating on each chunk
um
so that's so that's something about okay
so i've
i've you know returned this table
and maybe i just want to do a simple
ensemble which is uh averaging or the
all the coefficients i see for example
um so because now this is a data frame i
just
use normal multiplier syntax so this
screen is very very very
convenient for doing things like that
you you have a big data set you
distribute them to small chunks you fit
a model in each chunk
assuming that your chunks are now
distributed correctly or sampled
correctly then you just create really
simple ensemble models
like some type of packing models for
example just by
you know returning the
fitting a model for each chunk and just
combining the results together and of
course
some of you may have come across the
speed grm packages or the big
glm packages or scopic lm packages and
these are packages that can take a large
data set
for example talk to a sql like database
and fit a model on the whole data
without um doing some kind of averaging
like i've done here
and i've implemented a function called
dfgim so df of course stands for this
screen
um
and gim is just a normal glm
i use the normal big gim syntax
unfortunately in this syntax you can't
do a dot
but that's not necessarily a limitation
of
the disk frame implementation is more
because the underlying implementation
like big glm or speed grm also don't
take a dot so i can't just um
i did not try to be too cute and try to
expand the dot uh and then do all of
that stuff but it's really just this
it's a convenient function that causes
underlying hydrogen so
um so if you want to do
the convenience of fitting it on every
single uh column you might want to just
write some loop to construct the formula
but
uh or use some other uh i believe some
some techniques where you can just
construct this very quickly but
uh
but anyway just called the fgrm uh it
will just go ahead and fit the models on
this large dataset and it does it in a
way that doesn't uh break the memory
because
i believe the the packages that
implemented the [ __ ] for these also
loads the data chunk by chunk and kind
of just
go through the data and and still come
up with the right regression so yeah so
it's finished
and you can do
say summary
on the model just like normal
so just one big model and you can see
that it says it's a large data
regression fitted by this
formula and it's fitted on the whole
data set there
so
um yeah
so
i see that there's some a couple
questions here um
is the status store on your local ripple
um the data is stored in my local folder
actually um
so i so in this demo there's no no use
not using anything like um
you know your s3 buckets and whatever
it's just literally all the data is
stored on my local laptop computer um so
it's loading for my local computer
uh
where to put 200 gig on your local you
don't you don't you don't have even have
200 gig of data on your local c drive
okay um yeah um
well
i think it's
quite
common to have maybe 500 gig
of um even on uh yeah yes yes you're not
don't don't ever put
disk frame on a share drive or like a
network drive that's not gonna work
you you really
because the network transferring a lot
of data from network and it's not
which is not great for performance
that's yeah you need really need a local
ssd
where you store the data
what would you do is the original data
is stored in chunks fsg format already
but
data metadata doesn't exist for this
frames um i think that's that's that's
perfectly okay so um
like really simple
demo would be like what if i have a data
frame you know a just
three
and i'm going to use the fst package to
write it out
as an fst data
one dot
data
and
actually i just write it right here
um
so if i go to my my my data folder
i just create some
random folder called
testing
and i'm just going to write the data set
to that
[Music]
yeah so that's one data set uh i call it
testing to
one
fst
um no metadata whatsoever
it should it should just work so
four two six whatever
and so now this this folder should
contain just two fst files but nothing
else
so i should be able to do a disk frame
to it
no issues
so if i look at the content of the f1 it
tells me that f1 has two chunks
six rows in total one column yep so
um the dot metadata is not necessary
this thing can create if it
doesn't see that folder um
the important thing is just the
individual
files apologies for the
products
okay um so
yeah so i've gone through so basically
the point of demo is that you can use
um the plier verb that you're familiar
with and you can also run
r code directly
using the disk frame uh framework like
for example using the things like cmap
etc so um so
and
that's what you can do so just to recap
what's happened in some of the code you
see that once i do a library of this
frame the first thing i do is um
is um
is set up this frame to say how many
workers you can optionally say how many
workers you want
by default
this one will look at your
laptop work out how many cpu cores there
error and just use that number as the
default number of workers so each worker
is basically an r session that sits in
the background so every time you run
something on a disk frame
you'll try to you know send
the work off to these workers so for
example when you're doing you have 144
chunks you do a filter
you'll just send a filter to each of the
six workers
and each worker will do a filter on a
different chunk and return the results
another magic a lot of the magic that
happens in that it's done in the future
package
so yeah this thing probably wouldn't
have existed without a future package
which is quite awesome for
easily distributing workload like that
on a single laptop computer
and of course the way you
once you have a folder of c fst files
to make use of it you know i just
literally call the disk frame function
to convert this folder to a disk frame
then you can start operating using the
deployer verbs on on the disk frames
um so
for some
there's some support in this frame for
data table syntax
but
the support is
at this stage not as prioritized as
deployer but
at some point this would get picked up
again
and you know these are
just a selection of
well functions implemented um
in the
for this screen
and
number one takeaway for now is this
source keep function just always
if you if you know exactly what columns
you use in your operations
keep only those columns only those
columns into memory that's going to be
really speed things up a lot
okay so i um
i think i've gone
a bit over time but um and i've talked
about cmap and how to use them
and i have some slides and of course
i've shown how to
call glms or this frame
potentially you may want
you could do the same tricks for like
things like xg boost or neural network
basically pass
chunks of data to each of these models
and
you know fit models in the using fit
neural networks and
booster trees using this frame framework
i have done some proof of concept they
they work to some degree but they're not
really emphasized at the moment the only
implementation of a
statistical or machine learning
algorithm i've done is just the glm
which is backed by these two network uh
packages
so um
that's it that's all right all the
contents i have apart from the ones in
the in the appendix but um
yeah any any any questions i'm happy to
take
questions now
questions
thank you very much
i'll give you a applause since again no
one else can right now
we have a few questions actually there's
some other questions that you answered
not by reading them just in your
presentation you answered it later on so
i'm going to skip the ones that you've
already
answered about realizing you're being
asked
yeah um so first up this is uh let's see
well how just curious about your rig how
many cores does it have
this one has six cores
six okay so quarter or threads
six cores uh 12 hybrid threads
and i'm going to do a follow-up for this
person's question yeah you see a
performance like uh decreasing gains by
once you get past physical cores into
threads
physical causing the threat so like i
know like for like some like tree based
algorithms like using more using um
if they have using more than the number
of physical course doesn't really do you
much better like once you start using
like if you have six physical cores
using eight threads doesn't do much
better than six
yeah yeah um yeah so
my my my my cpu has
six cores but
12 hybrid threads so each core is hyper
threaded
um but if you look at um when i do the
setup uh it will the setup will tell me
that i'm only starting up six workers
so i i think from my testing it's that
yeah you even you have 12 hyper threats
it's probably not a good idea to use all
12. you're probably better off just
starting six um
number of workers as you have actually
physical cores
um yeah and uh of course
uh sometimes it's meant
sometimes your program is cpu bound but
a lot of times it's just limited by the
um
by the speed of your ssd or hard drive
so yeah it's basically sometimes this
frame just can't load data into memory
fast enough so sometimes even if you're
running an operation your cpu doesn't
get overheated it just because it's
loading data is quite slow but i think
there's
better and better
hard drive technology coming into the
market so those things could really be
really interesting going forward um yeah
what do you do if one of the chunks is
bigger than memory
oh that's a that's a good question so uh
typically when you do um when you when
you do the conversion when you run this
function uh it it
there's a function in there to try to
guess what would be the right chunk size
for your particular laptop
and so so therefore you can um do do
that now if just so happens that you
created a chunks on one computer you
kind of shift it to another computer
that's
that just doesn't fit at all
now there's an implementation of this
function called rechunk
in this frame so what
what the re-chunk does is basically says
well you have 100 chunks to start with
break it up into 200 chunks so you can
do that just just by saying
um
filling in the the um the
the right parameters so for example i
could recharge my ds frame as maybe n
chunks
vf
times two and you know if the algorithm
is smart enough when you do something
like that it should be able to just you
know load
maybe half of each disk frame and write
it out
but of course that would require some
kind of programming support in how you
do that so it doesn't do that perfectly
it this thing does kind of assume that
you're you know you're working with
computers
when you move it to another computer
it's kind of a similar power but
obviously that doesn't always work but
you kind of the great thing about fst
that you can handle
read part of the file
right you can just go um
you know from bro a million to two
million so you can read chunks of the
data and then
i guess you just read chunks of it write
it out and then you you resize your
chunks potentially using the recharge
function
but uh there's no no easy way to deal
with that i guess if you're moving
computers but within the same computer
you can probably use some functions like
n chunks or in chunk size to control how
big the chunks are
so
i i haven't had issues with this one but
this this is a pretty chunky um chunky
laptop
okay
yeah well um just to say uh result
written back isn't it when you join yes
yes when you join it it's written out as
a new one so um
so when i did the
uh when i did the r bind list
it's taken
it's taken
these two which sits at two different
locations
and outputs it in a temporary location
like this here so by default we should
do that because otherwise there's no
other logical way of doing it if um yeah
if it's not written out to a different
location yeah because you don't
obviously don't want to overwrite these
things
yeah
and speaking of um our bind list that's
very much from data table can you use
bind rows
uh i believe i haven't implemented bind
rows but let me yes i had
no i haven't implemented that but yeah i
i probably uh should at some point it's
the same same kind of thing but from the
deployer world yeah
uh
there's an earlier question about
are you only using physical ssds or do
you still get performance benefits if
you used virtual machine local drives
virtual machine local drives um
so
i'm not 100 sure about the technical
details so i
like for example if you're talking about
virtual machine and
got some sort of ebs attached to it and
the ebs maybe has a really high speed
network to the virtual machine
i haven't tested it out extensively but
yeah it's
it should be
that the limit should just be the the
limit of the
the transfer so because this frame
actually doesn't
uh the speed of this frame is really
determined by how fast it can transfer
data from a to b and then into memory so
if that connection is fast then
you should see the performance benefits
but i'm not sure about the technical
details about how what you mean by local
drive on a virtual machine so
of course they have to be
physically
or close or have a huge
connection between the two
if you have those properties then it
should be
as fast as those connections are yeah
yeah
um
how would you you did sort of touch upon
this but i think it's a slightly
different question um how do you
calculate metrics such as median or
quartiles and you did that's essentially
sorting which you know you touched on
yeah so uh so if you look at the things
like arrow
they they explicitly mentioned they used
an algorithm called dt digest which is a
approximation of the median because you
to do media you you need to do um
sorting so if you look at the
documentation i have on group by
you see that
when you're doing a group by this is on
the disk frame website by the way so
for these functions the computation is
exact but for median things like median
quantile iqr they are an estimate
because
as you imagine
sorting a 1.8 billion row data set is
just too expensive so we tend to just
use estimates for these and this is sim
this is true for almost everything like
spark does it
arrow i believe i read recently does
that
um so it's kind of like a limitation but
i did some tests on some real world data
sets
it's surprisingly close to median it's
actually to the actual actual medians
like
sometimes there's no no difference so
yeah
uh correct can't be done it's an
estimate yeah all right
cool
um then can you use sf objects with disk
frame
us
so what object sf they're like uh
spatial data frames
okay
i i get asked that a lot actually um
i honestly don't know enough about it to
to say but i think i say
i i just don't know um
but i think this frame as of now works
directly on fsts only so
and fsts i don't think you can save sf
objects as fs fsts now i think
well i i don't know how fast i store
they store this data frame so i i just
don't have that knowledge to answer that
so yeah
um yeah so unless it can be stored as a
fst or in some
table form
then the answer is no yeah
okay
um and this one's for me you mentioned
xg but you haven't implemented yet yeah
i think they have a um like you know
that special xgb.d matrix format can
actually be written to disk instead of
memory so it sounds like it wouldn't be
a huge leap not knowing all your crazy
architecture to get it to read your fst
files
yeah yeah no i i i actually have done a
uh
a proof of concept just
pushing the data into an extreme boost
it's worked
um it's i've got some code lying
somewhere but
i i had some issues with like in terms
of like performance or and i just didn't
have the time to look into it
but as i mentioned that xgboos new
networks are possibilities but it's just
that the best performing ones are the
glm so i just kind of
i'm stuck with that for now uh yeah i
actually read some code and i
demoed it in other places but um
it's a possibility but not something i'm
probably
really
you know gonna immediately work on kind
of thing yeah
cool
so i'll go another question just came in
oh there's probably an answer to what we
said before um they're answering the sf
question uh you you're you could say
well i've raised forever now uh i'll
read it for everyone the sf package
geometry columns which are list columns
um they pre they cause right fst to fail
with this error message yeah
so i guess the question is can those
columns be written
into a format for example like parque
if they can
park
they theoretically can but there's like
a known issue that they can't so someone
wrote a geoarrow package to make it
possible but as right now parquet
doesn't nicely do it without this
geoarrow package making it happen
yeah i see
um so i i guess one of the things that i
i think this claim will
you know want to move towards it to work
with other formats and fst directly
because actually the infrastructure is
the same the code is almost the same
so
if the data set can be at some point
written to something like a parquet or
some other format
that kind of can sit in chunks
then yeah it
could be could be adapted uh this frame
could be adapted but
because i i've kind of no knowledge in
that area sf never worked in that geo
area kind of not something that
i'll kind of jump into and say okay i
want to implement that but yeah
i've been asked that a lot i might you
know look into
what that is actually about and see what
can be done
i think i might have even asked you that
on twitter at one point
yeah
maybe it's some sometime in the future
but definitely not in the near future
yeah yeah
okay sf format is compatible with arrow
uh is it
sure
okay not sure sort of if they they say
it is but there's like a known bug that
it's not but there's this person who i
don't remember their name is working on
um geo arrow geo is geo
geo arrows what they're calling anything
so hopefully soon
yep um
since you sort of mentioned rapids
earlier think we're never going to get
disk frame on gpu
that's an interesting question um
theoretically if uh there's a convenient
way to call gpu functions on r and
and you know if your data continues to
sit on disk um
then you could potentially see uh where
you core are
uh
as i mentioned you can call it directly
just call our code from the disk frame
so
like uh like here so imagine if there's
a gpu function
that reads the data and do some
processing
uh and that function is available in r
then yeah potentially you can just call
it in disk frame or
and and and this frame could potentially
make use of that so for example suppose
you have a
suppose you have a function called you
know gpu group by you know
and that group by takes input from some
data input or whatever it may be
and suppose this data input can be
chunked
then i could just
create a disclaimed version of this like
maybe this screen
for this frame something like that
and it will make use of the gpu
functionalities directly because i'm
literally just calling our code
potentially
but i haven't seen that kind of
development yet or maybe i just haven't
been kept up to date on the what's
happening with the gpu side of things
and i i have honestly i had a few issues
trying out those gpu data manipulation
packages
they tend to be a bit harder to set up
sometimes also doesn't work that well on
windows
and potentially um
for a lot of the operations because the
gpu memories are quite limited
you end up having to do some a lot of
gymnastics about how you move data
around
and i think there's a benchmark
somewhere that shows that um
you know
it's gpu doesn't always win out all the
time at this stage so
i say it's an area to watch
how how well they
become how how much better the
technology becomes and how easy it
becomes to use
but i i honestly don't know enough to to
talk more about that it's just from
i only talk from my kind of how i feel
when i try them just um
uh
yeah it's uh work in progress i say yeah
cool
yeah all right i will give everyone else
just another minute see if there's any
last-minute questions there often are
the sliding underneath the wire
um while i wait for everyone to
anyone i guess to ask a last-minute
question i just want to uh give a round
another round of applause to zj for
coming giving this talk so thank you
everyone if you want to throw in some
clap emojis whatever you'd like to do
um and i think there's an excellent
presentation we had a bunch of you know
extra memory formats and it's pretty
cool to see this and we'll see next
month about wtb we've got a we have a
long string of them i see you're pulling
up some um
um benchmarks from h2o
yeah um
i believe this benchmark may may have
been kind of defunded recently i'm not
sure but um
yeah cudf it's uh it performs quite well
but
you wouldn't say it's uh it outperforms
you know it's a more traditional not not
more traditional that you know the new
kids on the block like polars and data
frames and julia like just by looking at
let it um
so yeah it's not um
it doesn't feel like it's gonna blow
existing tools out of the water
just by looking at this yeah very cool
it's always good to see some you know um
reality checks everybody talking about
this hype
yeah
we did get another questions thinking uh
do qs objects need to be changed to csv
before they can be changed to fst uh to
use disk frame
i don't think so i if i if i'm my memory
serves me right qos is kind of like a
new thing that people have started using
to save the rts
file so so like it doesn't have to be
like imagine if you just have a bunch of
files in there like qs
uh qs files
um you can just for example do
like even even our apply would work um
just say
and then you have a function called qs
file and then you you do something like
read
uh
qs i can't remember what the function
was a qs file
and
presumably at this point this would be a
data frame and what you do is you just
go
add chunk
to df
disk frame
so okay and you would do something like
this frame will be set up here this
frame would be like this frame
to this location you know
xyz
yeah then you just call this
it doesn't it doesn't have to be
converted to csv first you can just read
it directly
call add chunk to add it to this frame
um and that's
as simple as it gets in terms of
converting
non-csv formats to um disk frame yeah
yeah
qre yeah i i haven't used those packages
um extensively but you get the idea kind
of that's yeah just call add chunk and
just literally read this and add it add
it as a chunk to this frame
yeah
nice of course you can also do things
like um once you read it so
as disk frame
so you end up with a list of these
frames here and then you just do r bind
list disk frame
to pick this frame
something like that so you can just yeah
if
if this is a data frame just convert it
to a disk frame using this function so
you end up with a list of these frames
and just outbind them
or you know if you if you want to be
cute you can do future you know future
apply do it in parallel
it's possible yeah
yeah
and i think we shall uh be uh get around
the process of all the live coding we've
seen and there's always a perilous
journey doing live coding and you don't
have to plug so that's great
cool all right thank you
so i think we've wound through
that there's a bunch of questions i
didn't ask because you just happen to
answer them during your talk so like we
will not touch them like there's just a
bunch of things someone asked and you
just happened like 10 minutes later to
answer it so we won't even you know go
that i mean i'll just give you a hint
like asking about like um
network drop well you answer that one
but there's other questions about like
data table syntax and you just happen to
show the data table syntax so
there's a question about like map and
you showed cmap so you covered all the
questions about even knowing them so
that was awesome
um so yeah so thank you very much for
being here we see someone saying uh
walter's saying life coding rocks and it
does so thank you very much uh thank you
for being here of us thank you everyone
for attending uh we look forward to next
month
we have duckdb the following month we
have the brooklyn bridge we have the
conference in june we have jobs at job
postings lots of good stuff happening so
uh before we leave everyone one more
just round of applause virtual applause
for zj is a very big thank you coming to
us from literally all our oh not all the
way around the world literally halfway
around the world both in both directions
so thank you for coming us to us and uh
spending your day with us
all right my pleasure thank you very
much
and everyone see you next month alright
see you guys